henri guaino est l'invité de preuves par
3 bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
ancien conseiller spécial durant cinq
ans de nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui
parlementaire vous êtes très présent
dans le débat public avec vos idées
henri guaino avec votre livre également
la nuit et le jour on vous racontez vos
souvenirs le plume du chef de l'état et
vous le défendez également avec force et
par quel livre de souvenirs bien sûr
bien sûr ce également votre engagement
dans ce dialogue imaginaire avec eux un
instituteur votre instituteur ce qui
nous ramène à votre parcours personnel
on en parlera dans la troisième partie
de cette émission avec perrine tarneaud
de public sénat
et puis suzette bloch de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire nous
rejoindra d'abord pour parler de la
crise à l'ump cela dans 15 minutes
environ et puis les téléspectateurs
comme chaque semaine peuvent intervenir
dans l'émission par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque et d'orange
henri guaino on le sait vous le répéter
régulièrement vous êtes un partisan du
nucléaire et du réacteur ep air dont le
chantier de flamanville connaît un
nouveau dérapage financier
la facture va atteindre désormais 10 et
df 8 milliards et demi d'euros
elle a plus que doublé en sept ans c'est
vraiment être dérapages total oui mais
c'est pas tout à fait anormal savez
c'est une passe quelque chose de très
complexe
un apn et quand on construit premier on
apprend qu'on pense qu edf et arrive à
tous les acteurs qui travaillent sur ce
projet apprennent au fur et à mesure
donc on rien que de très normal pour
vous où il règne très normal pour une
opération de cette complexité
alors on entend les écologistes dire
qu'il est temps d'arrêter les frais oui
mais ses positions contre le nucléaire
donc chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
sur le nucléaire il faut arrêter les
frais il faut arrêter le nucléaire
voilà les sons les écologistes ils ont
une position idéologique bon pression
idéologique c'est le nucléaire c'est pas
bien voilà alors chaque fois qu'il ya
une difficulté bien
faut tout remettre en cause non je pense
que ça vaut la peine d'aller au bout de
ce projet de soin sont maintenant il est
il est engagé et c'est vrai que pour
construire le premier pour mettre tout
ça au point bien c'est très compliqué il
ya beaucoup d'obstacles qui n'était pas
prévisible d'un avancement ou chemin si
au bout puisque effectivement on ira au
bout de ce premier repère en tous les
cas en france 6 l échec industriel parce
qu'on voit au prix du kilowatt produit 1
on s'aperçoit que le père n'est pas du
tout compétitifs 1ce c'est vraiment la
fin du nucléaire pas cher youri d'abord
ça dépend par rapport à quoi
le rapport à l'éolien tiens oui c'est
une blague
non mais c'est une blague c'est une
comparaison complètement idiote
pardonnez moi je dirais aux liens ne
peut pas fournir de la pression
électrique de base l'éolien c'est
aléatoire
voilà et ça n'a rien à voir ce n'est pas
substituables on va pas remplacer toutes
les centrales nucléaires par vidéo lien
en plus il faudra mettre une dans le
jardin de chaque français vous imaginez
enfin dormir ici freins plus de 100
euros par mégawattheure et bien sûr
variable prg ça coûte plus cher que
l'éolien 83 mettre des éoliennes ou par
3 quoi la france éoliennes
vous allez voir si avec ça on va
s'éclairer c'est très bien nommés à la
fois raisonnable sanaa ce sont des
comparaisons qui n'ont aucun sens on
peut continuer notre vie nos il est vrai
que les chinois ils construisent
eux-mêmes 2 prd spa mais manifestement
ils tiennent les délais alors la cre
même pour se dire en france la
responsabilité des vf est engagé excusez
moi mais ils construisent pas tout ça et
construisent avec edf perd chinois voilà
donc on verra bien qu'on verra bien
comment fait baisser c'est clair que
l'expérience accumulée à flamanville
elle va servir
elle va servir à faire mieux sur les
réacteurs suivant mais vous savez le
père il a cette caractéristique
effectivement d'être cher mais d'être
beaucoup plus sécurisée que que les
autres réacteurs aujourd'hui sur le
marché
il faut savoir si ce qu'on veut est-ce
qu'on veut beaucoup de sécurité ou
est-ce qu'on veut moins de sécurité bien
moi je préfère comme citoyen beaucoup de
sécurité mais le nucléaire va rester
même avec beaucoup de sécurité encore
une
une source d'énergie est extrêmement
rentable et extrêmement économe par
rapport en plus c'est écologique un san
mames mais oui mais il n'y a pas de ya
pas de rejets dans l'atmosphère il ya
pas voilà il ya le problème des déchets
wébérienne et rien n'est parfait
quand même mais ça c'est du point de vue
du réchauffement climatique au mieux à
voir
il vaut mieux avoir le nucléaire que des
centrales thermiques alors vous dites le
ps ça n'est que le premier flamanville
mais on n'imagine pas le lancement d'un
jeu diable de l'enfance en tous les cas
on a deux puisque arriva en effet un en
finlande il pleuvait difficultés
également mais en france il y avait le
projet de penly également en seine
maritime
ces taux ne s'est pas dopé hier c'était
le on avait présenté sa comme le
deuxième qui vient de l'abandonner
avec l'alternance politique vous le
regrettez oui je le regrette parce que
là encore c'est l'effet de série qui va
permet d'améliorer le savoir-faire et de
l'aligner en de gagner en efficacité
parce que vous soutenez le gouvernement
qui est en butte même que quelqu'un dans
une situation d'affrontement avec les
écologistes je pense notamment à la
question de l'aéroport notre dame des
landes
écoutez le que n'aurait-on dit nicolas
sarkozy
on avait utilisé à la force publique
elle que tant de brutalité pour faire
partir les manifestants le jeu
ce projet est un projet qui avait été
actée par tout le monde
la droite avec voilà aujourd'hui pas le
sens de la droite la gauche
bon ce qui est quand même un peu plus
fort c'est que on abandonne tous les
grands investissements des tgv le canal
seine-nord déterra et font garde et on
garde que celui là c'est un peu curieux
tout de même avant et comment vous
l'expliquez c'est un projet cher au
premier ministre
c'est un projet cher au premier ministre
voilà jeu
voilà maintenant je suis pas sûr que
l'urgence absolue de ceux de cet
aéroport s'imposait avant tous les
autres projets si on abandonne tous les
autres c'est quand même un peu curieux
alors que l'on ne garde que celui là
voilà quant à la problématique des
aéroports et est une pratique compliqué
je pense qu'elle fausse il a regardé par
rapport à l'idée de faire une autre
grande plateforme pas trop loin de paris
c'est peut-être un projet aussi qu'on a
abandonné trop vite alors parlons du
dossier mittal si vous le voulez bien
henri guaino puisque vous avez soutenu
le projet de privatisation transitoire
du site de florange c'était l'option qui
était avancée par arnaud montebourg j'ai
pas dit ça
ah ah ah bah lui il a compris comme ça
n'est pas dit ça j'ai dit que l'option
de la prise de contrôle temporaire de la
nationalisation temporaire et 900 qu'on
pouvait pas écarter d'un revers de la
main et j'ai dit qu'il fallait
s'interroger vous allez voir c'est pire
que ce que je discerne à mon tour savoir
si d'abord si c'était indispensable
deuxièmement si c'était mieux de le
faire sur le site de florange sur
l'ensemble des actifs sidérurgique de
mittal
parce que c'est une option d'ailleurs
que nous avons étudié ce avions étudié
quand nicolas sarkozy est président de
la république c'est un c'est un problème
de calcul économique se passe pas un
problème idéologique je ne vois pas
pourquoi on s'interdirait a priori de
faire une prise de contrôle temporaire
quand c'est nécessaire pourquoi vous
serez obligé toujours dire que l'état ne
peut jamais rien à rien on l'a fait
d'ailleurs sur alstom américains l'ont
fait sur general motors l'a fait sur le
système bancaire au moment où différents
exactement donc il faut regarder lire
ci-dessous regarder il faut regarder au
cas par cas
il faut faire du calcul économique panu
papa de
de la politique logique c'est une option
qui doit qui je ne vois pas pourquoi on
s'arrête de débattre toujours sur ce
sujet avant même d'avoir entamé ou
engagés réellement le dollar idée a été
débattue d'ailleurs il est approuvé par
le chef de l'état vont finalement ça
n'est pas l'option qui a été retenu au
général débattu franchement ça a duré
quelques jours on s'en est servi comme
arme dans la négociation avec mittal que
c'est tout en fait on a le sentiment que
le gouvernement n'a jamais souhaité
aller au bout de ce dossier
alors il ya un débat autour de l'accord
secret et qui a été conclu entre le
gouvernement et arcelormittal il a été
publié cet accord par le journal le
monde et qui dévoile que sur les 180
millions d'investissements annoncés par
lakshmi mittal en fait il y en a que 53
c'est à dire moins d'un tiers qui
relèveront d'investissement stratégique
est ce que pour vous cet accord est un
marché de dupes à la lecture des
dernières apparitions j'ai pas lu en
détail la corse qui vient de ils
viennent de ressortir
c'est un peu ça s'est un peu réduit
comme information maintenant je constate
qu'on était passé d'un repreneur qui
mettait 400 millions 1,1 me tall qui met
180 qui finalement m'est 50 33 4 mois
voilà c'est savez le problème le
problème de fond c'est de savoir quelle
est la stratégie réelle de mittal sur la
sidérurgie sur les actifs et d'erreurs
chic métal ces deux groupes qui fait
d'eux qui a deux activités une activité
minière est une activité sidérurgique
pour l'essentiel la question qu'on s'est
posée qui se posent toujours à laquelle
on n'a pas de réponse
s'il n'y a pas une stratégie cachée de
mittal pour petit à petit se retirer du
de la sidérurgie et démanteler celles
actives sidérurgique et sur lens
repliant sur les activités minières qui
rapporte beaucoup plus aujourd'hui par
des effets de rentrent parfaitement
compréhensible donc la question est la
suivante si mittal de vraiment se
désengager progressivement alors l'état
doit prendre ses responsabilités parce
que la filière sidérurgique en france
est une filière d'avenir
on sait 80 mille salariés de presque 80
mille salariés en direct plus tous les
utilisateurs
c'est une filière dans lequel la france
a une idée avant d'avancer enfin en
avant c'est une avancée technologique
extrêmement importante c'est pas du tout
de la vieille économie en déclin qu'on
devrait réserver au pays émergent c'est
bien un secteur qui avait marché
aujourd'hui en europe
non c'est bien vers des marchés en
europe a pas de marché en europe
aujourd'hui simplement il ya une
ralentissement de la voilà un
ralentissement de l'activité et et
l'industrie et synergies qu'elle est
soumise aux mêmes problèmes que toute
industrie alors pour accueillir
évidemment si vous avez si vous avez
l'euro fort si vous avez les charges
sociales à petit qui pèsent sur le
travail si vous faire si vous faites
tout pour que l'industrie ne soit pas
compétitive en europe bien du style pas
pour être clair henri guaino vous nous
dites que la révélation de cet accord
secret on avait des guillemets entre
mittal est le gouvernement valide encore
plus l'option de la nationalisation
transitoire de la sidérurgie au passage
je vous dis qu'on a fermé le dossier en
même de l'avoir ouvert et je vous dis
que 7,7 cet accord dont je ne connais
pas les détails me rappelle quand même
toutes les promesses faites à chaque
fois par mittal à tous les gouvernements
successifs et finalement jamais tenu
donc la question se pose toujours de
savoir quel est le véritable stratégie
de mittal et c'est cette question
laquelle il faut avoir une réponse avant
de trancher et 6
et si la stratégie mittal s'est de
démanteler des actifs sidérurgique en
europe et en france en particulier
alors je ne trouve pas anormal que
l'état étudie la possibilité de prendre
le contrôle des actifs sidérurgique en
trouvant des partenaires d'une
expropriation alors attendez tous les
investisseurs
il faut encore une fois fort et à l'ump
qu'on dise ah oui mais vous savez il ya
des qu'il ya des gens qui adorent la
caricature partout bon on dit des si on
peut dire des sottises
n'importe qui peut dire des sottises à
droite à gauche au centre faut pas
imposer le problème que ça évidemment le
discours qui a été tenu au départ et est
outrancier s'agit pas d'une une affaire
personnelle entre la france et mittal il
s'agit pas de dénoncer une entreprise
qui a sa propre propre logique s'agit
simplement de réfléchir aux intérêts
nationaux et aux responsabilités de
l'état
là la sidérurgie c'est stratégique
voilà et c'est une en plus c'est une
activité de proximité
l'industrie de proximité parce que elle
doit être aussi proches de ceux auxquels
elle fournit des produits
la france n'a plus de minerai de fer
mais elle provoque beaucoup de beaucoup
de ferraille qui peuvent être recyclés
les exploiter les recycler bon donc il
ya énormément à faire dans ce dans ce
domaine c'est une filière d'avenir
c'est une filière stratégique en tout
état de cause la france ne peut pas se
désintéresser du soc de là on a ce qu'on
dirige la main entre montebourg et
heroes vous choisissez montebourg dans
ce dossier oui mais encore une fois la
forme était pas bonne à faire baisser
leurs parents n'étaient pas de new bell
à l'euphorie vous venez de valider
l'option le le fond moi je préfère
toujours jemaye roulant au le
volontarisme à l'absence de volonté
voilà je vais si le résultat est
missionné arnaud montebourg c'est son
problème sinon votre avis non je n'ai
pas d'avis qu'on n'est pas d'avis même
s'ils voulaient pas l'exprimer c'est
pour cela j'ai pas d'avis c'est son
problème non mais j'ai des questions aux
ministres savoir si la miss doit
démissionner ou pas quand il est
désavoué
c'est son problème une question avant de
parler de ça que c'est qu'une fois de
plus il n'y a pas de ligne politique ya
pas de cap bon et quand l'une des leçons
de notre ministre jérôme cahuzac
on le sait à la pointe de la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale
et selon le site mediapart il a détenu
pendant de longues années un compte non
déclaré
l'union des banques suisses à genève
alors il dément il dénonce une calomnie
on ne sait pas vraiment où est la vérité
en tous les cas mediapart dit avoir
beaucoup de renseignements même des
documents censés prouver la vérité moi
non plus ou non plus non plus j'ai
appris que mediapart sans brouiller
parfois dans la vérité donc moi je ne
ferais pas ce que les socialistes ont
fait nicolas sarkozy pendant cinq ans je
ferai pas de procès d'intention
je n'en sais rien laissons monsieur
cahuzac assurer sa défense
et puis nous verrons bien merci pour
cette première partie on va parler donc
de l'ump maintenant avec suzette bloch
de l'agencé france presse qui va nous
rejoindre mais d'abord le point sur les
hostilités henri guaino à l'heure tout
de même où les belligérants se parlent
eux fabrice qu'une est l'image est
symbolique françois fillon invité à la
conférence des présidents de l'assemblée
nationale depuis ce matin son
rassemblement ump fort de 72 députés
exister a gagné son temps de parole une
scission qui amusent à gauche jusqu'au
premier ministre on a aidé à messieurs
les députés
monsieur le président du groupe pardon
ump c'est bien ça je me suis pas trompé
allez allez françois fillon est donc
allé au bout de sa logique en créant son
propre groupe de parlementaires un moyen
de maintenir la pression alors que
s'ouvrent les négociations de la
dernière chance
je n'ai pas rencontré de parlementaires
qui souhaitent maintenir 7,7 cette
scission cette dissidence à terme donc
je pense que
tout est mis en route depuis hier pour
arriver non seulement renoué les fils
n'a trouvé une issue à la crise car le
message principal depuis lundi c'est
qu'ils se parlent eux françois fillon et
jean françois copé se sont lancés dans
une série d'entretiens des tête à tête
sans lieutenant et surtout sans
commentaire ils se parlent et c'est une
très bonne chose et ils se parlent pas
par médias interposés vous leur ferez
vous regrettez peut-être en tout cas
c'est comme ça que l'on peut avancer
c'est donc une grande évolution est en
quelque sorte ça répond à la demande
pressante de nicolas sarkozy l'ancien
président a pesé de tout son poids pour
engager ces rendez-vous de la dernière
chance
principal point de désaccord la date
d'une nouvelle élection 2014 pour jean
françois copé françois fillon lui
souhaite
un autre vote mais dans trois mois
maintenant voilà si
la semaine prochaine on n'a rien trouvé
on pourra considérer que le divorce est
consommé
mais ce ne n'est pas ce que souhaite la
majorité des députés de l'ump à l'ump
chacun attend l'annoncé d'un compromis
signal d'une sortie de crise
il sera alors temps de mesurer les
conséquences pour le parti et pour deux
hommes engagés dans un bras de fer qui
devrait laisser des traces
voilà donc suzette bloch de l' agence
france presse nous a rejoint henri
guaino bonsoir vous êtes bonsoir
monsieur vive nous alors aujourd'hui
vous avez vécu en quelque sorte une
journée historique
deux groupes ump à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez participé à la réunion du
groupe canal historique celui de jean
françois copé que ressent-il vous tient
pas le groupe de jean françois copé un
groupe ump points que ressentez vous moi
j'ai adhéré un groupe ump j'ai été élu
avec une étiquette ump et un groupe pour
la spa le groupe jean françois copé lui
appartient pas et c'est pas lui qui dit
très bien vide et j'ai pu ressentir vous
voit une grande tristesse beaucoup
d'affliction aussi parce que c'est
affligeant
voilà c'est affligeant on a savez un
groupe parlementaire c'est pas un parti
politique c'est une institution de la
république qui a des devoirs et en
particulier les députés ont des devoirs
non pas vis-à-vis de l'ours des
adhérents de leur parti mais des
français qui les ont élus ils ont des
devoirs vis-à-vis de la nation vis-à-vis
de la république vis-à-vis de la
démocratie et je trouve navrant que on
mélange les problèmes de partis avec
cela vous déprime home de primes non non
ça me déprime pas mais je trouve ça
affligeant
la branlée je veux mais copé et fillon
se parlent entre eux sans trop ce qui se
passe au groupe the lady jasmin c'est
une faute morale d'avoir créé un
deuxième groupe c'est je le dis à tous
mes amis qui font partie de ce groupe
encore une fois parce que nous avons des
devoirs et c'est une faute morale de ne
pas les remplit faut dissoudre mais oui
il faut le dissoudre
c'est mais ça n'a rien à voir avec notre
et notre débat on va constater les
pressions enfants se voient ça fait
pression sur qui que ce soit parlait
d'une faute morale concernant la synchro
d'industriel puisqu'il a parlé d'une
fracture morale entre alors oui à la
fracture morale pardon jeu chacun
s'invective sur le thème de la morale
écoutez la fracture m'en allais l'ump il
n'y en a pas il n'y a pas les bons d'un
côté les mauvais de l'autre il n'ya pas
ceux qui ont de la morale d'un côté ceux
qui ont à moelle de l'autre simplement
faire un groupe
oui ça c'est une faute morale on
pourrait s'en passer mais c'est une
faute morale vis-à-vis d'encore une fois
de ceux qui nous ont élus donner un
mandat apparemment n'a rien à voir très
vite et bien tant mieux
voilà tant mieux mais ça veut pas dire
pour autant qu'il n'y a pas un problème
à l'ump qu'il faut là où il faut pas de
résoudre
je veux dire simplement ce qui est
navrant est affligeant c'est de mélanger
les deux voilà si je trouve ça
insupportable et en même temps vous avez
dit que monsieur copé est un président
contesté mais c'est non je rends moi
personne dorado j'ai pas envie de
distribuer des des satisfecit des
certificats de bonne conduite c'est pas
mon rôle d'abord aujourd'hui se parlent
enfin ils se parlent en clair si nous
avions compté ils se parlent jusqu'à
présent et encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
on n'arrivait plus à se mettre dans la
même pièce même pas je voulais déjà dit
pour sur d'autres plateaux pour
s'engueuler donc quand même et quand on
en arrive là c'est tant mieux au moins
au moins au moins ils sont dans la même
pièce aux noix et peuvent se parler et
même si c'est pour s'engueuler c'est
déjà un progrès donc je vais pas je vais
pas venir perturber cesser ses premiers
pas on verra ce qui va sortir de ces de
ces discussions
il faut en sortir il faut rendre le plus
vite possible la parole aux militants et
aux adhérents de façon à ce qu'on sorte
de cette situation là mais d'une façon
ou d'une autre il faudra revoter
générant ça c'est ça on verra bien
peut-être qu'il faut demander aux
adhérents ce qu'ils en pensent aussi moi
j'étais à ses partisans et je les dis de
faire un référendum ce pas très glorieux
mais la situation dans laquelle on se
trouve à ne l'est pas c'est pas très
intelligent mais ce sens dans laquelle
on se trouve
elle n'est pas très intelligente non
plus bon comment on en sort on en sort
en redonnant le plus vite possible la
parole aux militants
et si on peut le faire par référendum
après tout pourquoi pas à leur demander
s'ils veulent voter ou pas et s'ils
veulent remonter dans quelles conditions
voilà je pense que au moins on aura
enfin le le choix des militants parce
que sinon on va contourneront mais de ce
que les deux camps semblent encore j'ai
pas dans un clan ça m'intéresse pas il
n'y a pas de camps ya pas de corps il ya
deux personnes un qui a créé un groupe
et qui est président du groupe
l'autre qui a été proclamé élu président
qui est à la tête du parti juridiquement
donc voilà c'est une sédition position
intenable pour les deux oui mais vous
même vous avez pris position pour
monsieur copé oui et alors
dont faisait bien situé dans un camp
maintenant je refuse cette idée de quand
moi j'ai plus présent j'ai dit que je
voter pour jean françois copé
j'ai participé à sa campagne je ne
regrette absolument rien j'ai dit dans
quelles conditions je faisais ce choix
et pourquoi pas recommencer ce soir mais
là vous me demandez mon avis sur ce qui
se passe et je vous dis que ce qui se
passe est intenable pour l'un comme pour
l'autre
mais l'histoire du groupe elle est
moralement condamnable et politiquement
la situation de l'ump aujourd'hui n'est
pas tenable il paraît que nicolas
sarkozy avait préparé un communiqué où
il disait ça on vous reprenez ce mot je
sais pas ce qu'il a préparé puisque vers
fin le mot mais d'abord il
je reprends un nid douillet où le
communiqué nicholas abbey voilà c'était
mon croyais je suis très fier vous voyez
qu'on se le dise choisiront suis très
fier de me promener en france est
d'entendre ce que disent les français
sur ce qui se passe sur cette question
regarde je ne parle jamais de ça je ne
dis jamais quand je les ai vus quand je
les ai vus ce qui m'a dit de quoi nous
avons parlé jamais jamais voilà je pense
que si on avait pu se comporter assez
intelligemment pour qu'ils ne soient pas
obligés de se mêler de cette affaire ni
directement ni indirectement
eh bien ça aurait été beaucoup mieux
pour tout le monde pour lui aussi et
pour lui et bien sûr aussi bien sûr mais
pour nous aussi pas dit il implique de
l'impliquer dans cette dans cette
affaire n'aurait jamais dû céder à
certains l'accusent d' implication
partisane madame laurence rossignol ça
madame laurence rossignol sénatrice ps
qui a interpellé le président du conseil
constitutionnel sur l'intervention non
mais quand on a réussi à les faire
franchement toutes ces sottises
en quoi en quoi l'impartialité du juge
constitutionnel nicolas sarkozy est elle
mise en cause par ce qui s'est passé
d'abord je vous rappelle qu'ils nient
s'être prononcé publiquement sur rien du
tout après qu'il ait un lien affectif de
proximité avec l'ump est ce que
quelqu'un le découvre c'est franchement
est ce que c'est parce que monsieur
dumas il avait pas un lien que le parti
socialiste monsieur joxe il n'avait
aucun lien avec le parti socialiste
quand il était président du conseil
constitutionnel
monsieur jean louis debré est tombé de
la lune bon c'est normal et les anciens
présidents de la république ils ont tous
une famille politique d'origine
donc tout ça est un débat tout ça est
grotesque et dans la les deux
protagonistes n'ont pas les deux corps
ils sont d'accord maintenant pour qu'il
ya un nouveau vote pour le vote je pense
que c'est une eva la psychédélique table
donc maintenant là
la pierre d'achoppement c'est qu'en
avant le comment quand et quel est votre
avis à mon avis est qu'il faut peut-être
devant deux militants voilà oui pour
demander du temps quand il quand même
plus possible le plus vite possible je
pense que le plus vite sera le mieux
parce que on voit bien qu'on peut pas
sortir de cette histoire simplement par
un arrangement entre deux personnes dans
un coin des portes fermées je ne nie pas
un arrangement entre deux états majors
bros et voilà c'est sur la place c'est
une affaire publique tant qu'il faut le
plus vite possible demande aux militants
ce qu'ils en pensent alors ce qu'il faut
revoter tout de suite est-ce qu'il faut
d'abord leur demander quand ils veulent
voter s'ils veulent voter quand et dans
quelles conditions la non importe quelle
solution sera la bonne
il faut en sortir en redonnant la parole
au geste et les statuts de l'ump
bah oui pensez qu'il faut l'inclure dans
ce oui je pense que ça serait bien oui
je pense ça serait bien en tout cas tout
ce qu'on pourra pas recommencer
on pourra par voter dans les mêmes
circonstances que ça soit je vois ça
demain ces règles sont absurdes jeu
j'avais dit quand moment de la douceur
des parrainages que sa place est la
démocratie de l'ump entre la corse est
de la corée du nord celle de cuba j'ai
pas changé d'avis et les faits me
donnent plutôt raison
non mais c'est vrai de verrouillage ne
pouvait conduire qu'à un désastre si
vous exercez de réforme des statuts de
l'ump
votre retour dans la compétition on
n'est pas là dû prendre un peu d'avancé
à lui mais moi j'ai pas envie de prendre
l'avancé dans les situations où on est
sortons d'abord de 2,7 de cette
situation enfin de cesse que à votre
avis où cieux de vous mon cher monsieur
des militants
monsieur sion monsieur copé sont
disqualifiés son discrédit l'histoire
montre qu'en politique en france on est
rarement définitivement disqualifié
c'est sûr que cela n'a amélioré l'image
qu'ils de l'année de l'autre voilà mais
vous savez en tout cas pour vous il faut
plus que deux compétiteurs ils
s'asseyaient il n'existe aucune
démocratie au monde où on ôte au risque
de personnes à se présenter ça n'existe
pas c'est ça ne peut conduire qu'à une
situation de ce genre
regardez il était verrouillé sur les
parrainages c'est est verrouillé parce
qu'on présentait des trios et que donc
on pouvait négocier avec personne je
vois là vous avez 3 personnes vous
pouvez pas donner le poste de secrétaire
général à quelqu'un pour pour faire une
alliance pour aussi d'équilibrer le jeu
bon et en plus on avait inventé un
système extraordinaire c'est l'ump l'a
fait preuve quand même d'une imagination
débordante
on avait deux urnes l'une pour les
hommes vous choisissiez le nom de l'un
ou de l'autre et à côté vous avez lu ont
des idées avec deux bulletins de vote
d'habitude c'est la même chose vous
choisissez les idées portées par
quelqu'un mais là non choisissez d'un
côté les idées et de l'autre les
honneurs aux compositions idéologique à
laquelle vous appeliez les l'urne pour
les idées mais comment vous des camps
politiques les idées swan soit avec toi
désincarné
comment voulez vous qu'elle soit
incarnée dans une motion pour vous les
cinq ans il faut incarner par des hommes
vous pouvez pas vous choisissez vos
responsables et par ailleurs vous
salissez vos idées mais quand même en
marche la tête me connaissait un an
monde ça se passe comme ça quand c'est
une élection c'est parce que j'ai des
chefs de motion commune parti socialiste
enfin je sais pas vous mais pourquoi pas
en tout cas en tout cas dans toutes les
élections les gens portent un projet
portant décembre il faut sur une
profession de foi pour les 1/2 motion
pour les autres de programmes de ce que
vous voudrez mais enfin je quelqu'un
vient devant les électeurs dit voilà ce
que je crois voilà ce que je pense voilà
mon projet ou au parti socialiste voilà
ma motion s'est marré d'hier était quand
même bien quand même
est ce que le nicolas sarkozy
que jamais ses chances pour revenir en
mais le problème se pose pas comme ça
c'est un truc de france
comment est ce que vous le posez à
l'heure vous mais le problème c'est tout
c'est nicolas sarkozy est parti l'a dit
lui-même et l'idée de redevenir un
français parmi les français il ne s'est
pas posé en recours
il n'est pas parti dans cet état
d'esprit est maintenant personne ne sait
ce que la vie nous réserve dit ce que
seront les circonstances dans les
destinations aidé mais qu'est ce que
vous lui souhaitez vous moi je lui
souhaite d'être heureux pas très bien
être heureux épanoui sur le plan
politique pour demain mais il n'y a pas
de il a pas d'ambition politique
peut-être que demain les circonstances
seront que le pays aura besoin de lui
viendra alors l'instant on savoure le
moment de savoir si lui il éprouve
l'envi le besoin ou s'il se sent le
devoir de répondre à six points que le
pays est en buzz je n'en sais rien savez
vous pensez à quoi
mais je ne pense à rien du tout je pense
qu'en général de gaulle est parti en 46
personne ne savait comment le pays
pourrait avoir un jour de nouveau besoin
de lui
et puis un jour le pays avait besoin de
lui voilà mais c'est sa constance
pourrait se présenter à nouveau
mais n'importe lesquelles sa pleine
valeur de nicola sacco une crise
politique une crise sociale un vide
politique je n'en sais rien je n'en sais
non pas pour résoudre la cuisse d'un
parti tout ça et protège ni ses injures
serait dur et bien cela dure mais je
pense que c'est pas tenable et qu'on
peut pas salir et très optimiste mais je
suis ni optimiste ni pessimiste et je me
dis que aujourd'hui au départ n'est pas
encore sorti de cette saison j'espère
que demain on fera j'espère qu'à force
de se parler
la raison va venir à l'un comme à
l'autre et puis à nous tous parce qu'on
est tous soucis responsable de cette
histoire mais ma mère a qualifié jean
françois copé que vous avez descendu
deux braqueurs qu'est ce que vous
répondez à l'élu vert que pour vous
sauver
qui s'occupe des braquages chez les
verts ce sera déjà pas mal rappelez vous
rappelez vous des primaires chez les
verts rappelez vous de la manière dont
ça s'est passé
un jeu je parle des leçons de démocratie
là franchement ils sont pas très bien
placé pour en donner
une toute toute autre sujet je voudrais
savoir à titre personnel si vous êtes
pour le mariage ou contes pour tous ou
contre le mariage vous inscrire mais là
dessus je suis contre je suis contre le
fait que l'on touche à l'institution du
mariage pourquoi parce que l'institution
du mariage
ça concerne non pas l'amour ça compte
les sentiments que l'on peut que deux
êtres peuvent éprouver l'un pour l'autre
non mais non non l'institution du
mariage sa valeur profonde sont nus
c'est une institution une institution
voilà et pourquoi cette institution
existe-t-elle dans toutes les sociétés
organisées depuis qu'il existe au monde
ont souhaité organiser parce que parce
que c'est cette institution permet de
mettre de l'ordre dans la filiation et
qu' aucune société organisée ne peut
vivre dans s'il ya du désordre dans la
filiation la question fondamentale qui
est posée est celle de la filiation le
mariage bien sûr il ya de l'amour dans
comme la rénovation filiation groupe le
dans toutes les industries créatives de
la réalité et vous allez mettre aucune
aucune qu'un ordre vous a laissé la
porte ouverte vers l'adoption et c'est
la porte ouverte vers la procréation
pour autrui
vous pensez que lorsqu'on a plus par an
on a juste on a plus de mères et de
pères on a juste par an et par an 2 est
bien avec ça on est de l'ordre dans la
filiation mais enfin si plaisanterie
alors au point mais moi je conçois très
bien des gens soit pour je dis
simplement que moi je suis contre et je
suis content parce que je pense que
c'est pas un problème de sentiments
c'est pas un problème de reconnaissance
d'une forme d'amour c'est même pas le
problème de reconnaissance d'une forme
de famille
c'est un point beaucoup plus profond qui
nous renvoie aux institutions qui
assurent le fondement de l'ordre social
total à 13 chantiers vous serez sur le
pavé parisien
oui à condition que y'a aucune outrance
dans cette manifestation s'il y en a je
la quitterais voilà je dis très bien
mais moi je vais plus loin je pense
simplement que quel que soit notre avis
aux uns et aux autres une question aussi
grave aussi profonde ne peut pas être
tranché par le parlement ce n'est pas
aux parlementaires à leur tranchée je
suis favorable à ce qu'on me donne la
parole au peuple
enfin quand même on la donne pour le le
droit de vote savoir si on doit donner
le droit de vote aux élections locales
aux étrangers il faut modifier la
constitution et donner la parole au
congrès soit soit au peuple et pour une
question aussi grave aussi profonde
on ne demanderait pas au peuple on se
contenterait d'un débat au parlement
mais ce n'est pas tenable internautes
public sénat va nous rejoindre mais on
s'arrête sur henri guaino le petit début
de mea culpa que vous formulez dans
votre livre comme plume de nicolas
sarkozy alexandra colinot il n'y a aucun
remords aucune critique qu'henri guaino
revient sur les cinq ans vécus nuitées
jours avec celui dont il était la plume
il n'y a que de la nostalgie et beaucoup
de tristesse le droit d'inventaire lui
est impossible
pourtant il ya des discours qui pèsent
sur le bilan du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy dans la transmission des valeurs
et dans l'apprentissage de la différence
entre le bien et le mal l'instituteur ne
pourra jamais remplacer le pasteur ou le
curé henri guaino qui voit à
l'instituteur l'origine du savoir et de
la liberté ne reconnaît là qu une demi
phrase maladroite mais il ya aussi le
discours de grenoble qui marque le
virage à droite de l'ère sarkozy
la nationalité française doit pouvoir
être retirée à toute personne d'origine
étrangère qui aurait volontairement
porté atteinte à la vie d'un
fonctionnaire de police ou d'un
militaire la gendarmerie lui le
gaulliste est revendiquée n'admet qu'un
problème de forme
enfin le fameux discours de dakar et
cette phrase drame de l'afrique c'est
que l'homme africain n'est pas assez
entré dans l'histoire
cette fois henri guaino l'est de
l'incompréhension je ne crois pas qu'on
soit
10 conçoit moment une erreur parce que
c'est l'expression d'une pensée qui est
en général plus complexe que ne le dit
le papier ou koné dit simplement
quelques résumés de presse tout cela ne
serait donc qu'un malentendu pas
d'erreurs politiques à mettre au passif
du quinquennat juste un problème de
style voilà perrine tarneaud nous a
rejoint bonsoir paris mon bonjour
bonsoir partout en rien au fait est-ce
que l'inventaire du quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy est toujours interdite d'abord
je n'avais pas interdit de réfléchir sur
ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on appelle droit
d'inventaire oui je pense qu'il est
interdit à tous ceux qui ont défendu
corps et âme b20 bec et ongles la
politique de nicolas sarkozy pendant
cinq ans voilà c'est passé à ses passes
et indécent de dire ou alors il faut
dire nous nous aurions peut-être pu
faire les choses autrement mais pas il a
mal fait les choses je trouve cette
distanciation particulièrement tamelaht
un équipement je voudrais revenir sur ce
pardon parce que là je trouve que ce
petit film était particulièrement
caricatural je voudrais revenir dessus
parce que peut pas continuer à faire de
la politique de cette façon je les trois
phrases que vous avez que vous avez
cités la première sur le prêt d'ailleurs
c'était pas celle là qui étaient c'est
un peu plus loin c'était gênant parce
que le fait de dire que l'indre
l'instant ne remplacera pas le prêtre
non ne soutiendront pas ce talent prête
pas plus que le prête nom en place
instituteur la foi et la raison la fois
le savoir ce sens il soit de choses
difficiles non celle là c'était un peu
plus loin quand il était question
semblait dire que le discours semblait
dire et voilà je vous rassure gilles su
produire plus semblé dire qu'avec vous
s'est pas d'autocritique c'est jeu
j'assume la responsabilité collective
mais voilà simplement je suis pas
responsable de cette demi phrase mais je
suis responsable de ne pas l'avoir vue
de l'avant la phrase sur la ceinture
il ya un petit morceau de phrase ou
ensemble président semble dire que y'a
une supériorité ses tuteurs sur le de
l'individu
c'est ainsi c'est pas celle que vous
avez cités qui ne pose aucun aucun
problème en tout cas mes yeux ça c'est
une demi phrase maladroite personne ne
pensait en réalité que le prêtre était
supérieur à l'instituteur bons contacts
voilà on a c'est une erreur très bien on
va pas en faire face à ça c'est pas un
débat idéologique il y en a pas puisque
je suis d'accord avec vous nous sommes
d'accord avec vous et que le président
sarkozy aurait parfaitement était
d'accord avec vous 2e
deuxième remarque sur le discours de
grenoble
la phrase que vous avez cités c'est
pareil le contenu disco donna où il
posait un problème de ton il posait un
problème parfois de désignation d'une
dune d'un groupe humain dans la vie mais
une motivation mais oui mais pas la face
parce que vous avez montré pardon je
voudrais revenir un instant sur la sur
la naturalisation
non vous vous dites vous parlez de la
nationalité mais là le retrait de la
nationalité pour des gens qui ont commis
des crimes particulièrement graves
il existe dans le droit français depuis
la libération
c'est le gouvernement provisoire du
général de gaulle qui l'a instaurée avec
tous les partis présents autour de la
table
personne depuis personne n'a songé un
instant à le supprimer
personne monsieur jean stern avait juste
réduit le champ d'application et ce qui
était proposé là c'était d'en élargir de
nouveau le champ d'application je pense
que c'était pas une bonne idée que ça ne
résoudrait pas les problèmes posés
mais ça n'était pas une tache sur la
république il faut il faut arrêter aussi
de raconter sinimalé s'arrêtera d'abord
enlever une phrase comme ça d'un
discours est toujours très malhonnête
surtout face à brest de discours vous
intéresse quand on s'adresse à des gens
qui ne l'ont pas lu qu'en plus les
critiques sont fait souvent par des gens
qui ne l'ont pas lui non plus c'est un
peu gênant alors cette phrase je réponds
toujours puisqu'on n'a pas le temps la
façon suivante quand aimé césaire poète
martiniquais noir de peau descendants
d'esclaves dit laissez entrer les
peuples noirs sur la grande scène de
l'histoire tout non trouve ça génial et
très bien et très moral quand on dit
voilà l'homme africain n'est pas assez
entré dans l'histoire c'est à dire ne
maîtrise pas assez sa proposition elle
n'écrit pas lui même assez sa propre
histoire vous dis c'est une honte et à
la honte
oui le scandale est ce qu'on m'a dit et
a parlé de l'homme africain c'est
raciste et parler de l'homme européen de
l'homme occidental de l'homme
méditerranéen ça ça n'est pas non mais
enfin tout ça tout ça est une caricature
absurde dans l' il n'y a pas de
nostalgie c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas
non plus juste l'aveu de quelques
problèmes de forme je suis désolé il ya
aussi la dénonciation du mensonge et de
la caricature dont le discours de dakar
a été un des exemples types on a raconté
n'importe quoi
vous savez moi un jour mon caricatures
d'hommes sa patiente et lascive ni
classe politique de notre part à
l'époque il avait 9 ans il est rentré
m'a dit papa tu sais les copains disent
qu'à la télé rend compte que tu es
raciste
voyez que ça m'a fait plaisir non mais
c'est regarde non mais c'est à dire
échanges non ça c'est pas de la vie
politique ça moi la politique je veux
pas en faire comme ça je peux en faire
avec des gens qui se comporte de cette
manière
un jeu pas traité de raciste avant avant
de traiter les gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord ils vont aller traiter de
fasciste ben c'était parfait
parfaitement nuit on a eu tout ça nous a
conduits bon et maintenant quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec quelqu'un on dit
qu'il est raciste
voilà mais moi je l'admets pas de
traiter de raciste voilà je ne l'admets
pas mais sous le quinquennat on parlait
du discours de grenoble et puis après
pendant la campagne et quand même il la
stigmatisation de certaines communautés
est ce que ça vous agiriez champagne non
pas dans pas dans le discours nicolas
sarkozy
il ya eu une tonalité peut être gênant
par moments mais il n'y a pas eu de
stigmatisation d'une communauté dans la
campagne nicolas sarkozy je réfute cette
accusation
une tonalité un peu droitière c'est ce
que voulait dire non pas droitière parce
que l'immigration la sécurité c'est pas
la droite c'est tout le monde et que les
parties les plus extrêmes qui s'empare
de ces sujets de façon caricaturale
ils sont pas de droite économique
existant dans les équipes ça dans la
tête
d'abord le fascisme n'est pas droite
c'est de droite et de gauche donc c'est
pas la droite n'y a pas de droitisation
ya juste que quand on se trouve enfermé
dans le cercle des militants et des
sympathisants et bien et qu'on se laisse
porter par pas par la salle on a
tendance à prononcer ses discours d'une
manière qui est parfois un peu dur
et quand en plus la télévision ne retire
qu'une phrase ou deux de tout un
discours parce qu'il est l'égalité des
temps de parole et qu'elle dure trois
semaines de plus que
non mais le problème c'est qu'on a été
on a été d'abord surpris de découvrir
les trois semaines de plus
personne ne l'avait bien intégré la
première fois quand une décision du
conseil constitutionnel et il s'est
passé dans mon livre je compterai c'est
qu'en fait il ya eu la sphère de bayonne
nicolas sarkozy a été agressée d'une
violence inouïe et après il s'est replié
après ça sur le sur le cercle étroit des
militants et des sympathisants vrai que
et que la drogue est reparti sur six
mois parce que ça pousse à finalement
ada s'est porté par les militants mais
il a pas on peut on peut discuter du ton
de cette campagne peut pas discuter du
fond ni des mots les mots employés dans
cette campagne n'a pas un que je récuse
il y en a pas un don j'ai honte voilà
même si je n'ai pas écrit tous les
discours aussi la ligne fixée par
patrick buisson à ce que ça c'est la
neige et celle de patrick buisson
n'était pas celle de nicolas sarkozy la
une de nicolas sarkozy était celle de
nicolas sarkozy
et nous l'avons tous accepté et si
j'avais eu le mot la moindre honte le
moindre problème de la moindre
indignation le moins de quatre
conscience je serais parti croyez moi
donc j'assume tout ce qui a été dit et
tout ce qui a été fait ça m'empêche pas
de de considérer qu effectivement il ya
eu parfois une tonalité qui pouvait
prêter à confusion et je ne dépendant
pas de jean-françois comme je le déplore
mais là aussi il ya des espaces de
campagne prête à confusion
voilà oui ça peut prêter à confusion de
la tonalité parce qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent se sentir agressés alors qu'ils
ne sont pas bons c'est dommageable et
oblige le regrette
oui je le regrette comment l'histoire du
pain au chocolat par exemple mais moi
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais sur les
pains au chocolat et sur le racisme anti
blanc quand j'ai pris position en face à
tous et j'ai dit ce n'est pas ma façon
de faire de la politique parce qu'un
homme politique ce niveau de
responsabilité n'est pas là pour attiser
les tensions il est là pour les apaiser
il n'est pas là pour dénoncer il a pour
apporter des solutions
bon mais cela est en jeu c'était un
dérapage de campagne mon gilet pas
racistes assez mais ça veut pas dire que
je parte je suis pas droite décomplexée
on n'a plus beaucoup de temps mais il
faudrait qu'on fasse tout une émission
pour savoir comment maintenant la droite
peut regagner cette bataille des idées
une dernière question pour finir cette
émission henri guaino qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la volonté de
cécile duflot de réquisitionner des
immeubles appartenant à des sans abri
pas compris qu est le hall est
réquisitionné des immeubles de l'église
a écrit moi j'ai pas lu la lettre encore
je parte en excuser moi la menace est
présente
je pense que je serai en train de
l'église comme une institution moral aux
deux sens du terme donc une astuce
morale qu'on peut réquisitionner une
société d'assurances ou je ne sais quoi
visionner les sociétés d'assurance les
banques les administrations mais je je
ne crois pas qu'elle se lancera dans la
réquisition des biens de l'église je
rappelle quand même que l'église
catholique comme tahir l'église possible
ce protestant tous les autres
communautés religieuses fait fait
énormément pour lutter contre
l'exclusion contre la pauvreté contre la
misère et elle n'a pas attendu madame
faut pour mettre ses biens à la
disposition des plus pauvres et des plus
vulnérables
boutin elle dit qu'à une catho lee
phobie qui se développe en france il ya
beaucoup de phobie qui se développe en
france et celle ci notamment
oui je sais être les cas nouveaux nous
c'est certain
c'est vrai ça existe aussi mais mais on
a dû s'adapter à des formes plus sérieux
qu'on trouve ça je trouve ça assez nul
et calcat ural mais voilà c'est pas la
peine de leur accord mais pas trop
indulgent avec deux ministres on a
entendu
arnaud montebourg et puis cécile duflot
mais non je pense qu'elle a de chances
de voir autre chose à faire que ce genre
de manifestation est celle du monde
bourboule penser aussi par ce genre de
sorties ou couteau chaud pour
nationalisation réalisation réquisitions
franchement franchement c'est une
caricature mais madame duflot fait un
peu de pub sur sur l'histoire des
églises et la nationalisation c'est un
ancien débat sérieux très bien sérieux
la réquisition non qu'il faut aborder
avec une forme d'indulgence pour les
honore merci pas une forme d'allégeance
de forme de sérieux de sérieux c'est ce
qu'ont essayé de faire et d'être avec
vous au cours de cette émission argué no
mercy mercy perrine bonsoir a très vite
le vrai courage gilles leclair s'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le monde
sait le faire nicolas sarkozy est parti
mais la crise est pas partir la
politique économique du gouvernement
je lui donnerai un zéro pointé tous les
matins à 8 heures 15
guillaume durand et gilles leclair
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconstruire sa
crédibilité
reconstruire sa popularité il faut pas
préjuger on peut juger après en
partenariat avec radio classique
l'invité politique
tous les matins à 8h 15 en direct sur
public sénat
bonjour à tous un lieu nous sommes à
vimy quelque part entre lens et arras
une histoire celle de la bataille
historique de la nation canadienne
oh
vimy n'est pas n'importe quelle bataille
d'ailleurs vimy n'est pas n'importe
quelle victoire non plus on le verra il
faut bien comprendre ici dans ces
plaines de l'artois en 1917 le front est
fixée alors il faut à tout prix enfoncé
les lignes allemandes en particulier
celle qui protège les très riches mines
de charbon de la région lensoise des
mines qui était tombé aux mains de
l'ennemi
dès le début du conflit de la grande
guerre marie lebon
fin août 1914 après trois mois de guerre
de mouvement le conflit se fige allemand
d'un côté alliés de l'autre chacun dans
sa tranchée c'est la guerre de position
une étape meurtrière du conflit qui va
durer plus de deux ans tout comme verdun
la même année les grandes batailles de
la somme marque en 1916 un tournant dans
la conduite de la guerre sur un front de
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
britanniques canadiens et français
jettent toutes leurs forces pour tenter
de percer les lignes ennemies les moyens
techniques et humains sont considérables
trois millions de soldats participent
aux combats quatre mois d'efforts
acharnés n'y feront rien l'impasse est
totale
de part et d'autre les troupes sont
épuisés les bataille de la somme reste
parmi les plus meurtrières de l'histoire
militaire de juillet à novembre 1916
elles feront toutes nationalités
confondues plus d'un million deux cent
mille morts blessés et disparus
on l'a bien compris ici en artois la
situation est bel et bien bloqués
regarder ses paysages autour de moi ces
paysages de bataille ces trous de bondy
parcelles le sol des paysages qui
témoigne de l'enfer que sue cette
bataille de vimy caroline iott vous êtes
étudiante vous êtes guide vous
accueillez les visiteurs ici sur ce site
de vimy c'est une fierté pour vous
d'être ici oui en fait en étant
canadienne est aussi en étant élève
d'histoire au canada c'est vraiment
quelque chose de pouvoir être ici
d'accueillir tous nos visiteurs et de
parler de l'importance de cette bataille
il y avait combien de canadiens sur ce
théâtre de la bataille
et si on parle de troupes de réserve et
d'artillerie et tout ça on parle
d'environ 5000 canadiens alors il faut
parler du général
bing c'était le général qui commandait
ses forces canadiennes il était lui-même
anglais et il a révolutionné la tactique
de cette bataille c'est à dire qu'il a
inventé la manière de faire qui a
conduit à la victoire
oui en fait la planification qui eut
pour cette bataille c'était très
important on eu beaucoup de
planification de fait de l'artillerie et
tout ça beaucoup de préparation aussi
les troupes canadiennes étaient ici tout
ici dès décembre 1916 et la bataille
était pas avant avril 1917 et ont pu
planifier et pratiquer beaucoup pour
cette attaque et pendant la bataille
elle même on est ce qu'on appelle un
barrage roulant
donc c'est un barrage d'artillerie qui
passe devant les troupes canadiennes qui
permet aux canadiens de bouger ici d'une
manière protégée mais aussi permet de
aussi pouvoir prendre des positions
d'une façon très concrète et de pouvoir
les garder aussi jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre chacun des soldats canadiens
connaissent et précisément son objectif
tous les canadiens avaient même eu une
carte géographique avec les détails et
de la bataille est donc savait
exactement où est l objectif et c'est un
des objectifs très précis qui bougeaient
vraiment de plus et plus loin sur le
long de la crête et on avait des troupes
aussi qu'il avait été en charge de
pouvoir prendre des positions qui
étaient fortifiée et tous les différends
seuls deux savaient exactement où était
leur objectif est donc si les lignes de
communication avait été brisée pendant
la bataille même on fait quand même
continuer donc ce qui avait été un échec
dans d'autres batailles comme la
bataille de la somme on
quand même plus savoir où est l objectif
à obtenir pour cette bataille ici merci
beaucoup caroline on le voit donc rien
n'a été laissé au hasard pour atteindre
la victoire dans cette bataille de vimy
une bataille qui s'est également
déroulée dans le sous sol
la guerre des tunnels
alors les voilà ces fameux tunnel de
wimille rejoint marc andré qui est
également étudiant également guide ici
sur le site de la bataille
on va aller visiter tout de suite c'est
tout-à-fait suivez-moi
ap
vous répondrez cet endroit est très
impressionnant tout à fait on est
présentement huit mètres sous le niveau
du sol
le souterrain convient dit en ce moment
s'appelle le souterrain grange à
l'origine il mesurait 1,2 km donc 1,2
kilomètres de souterrains qui ont été
creusés à la main dans la région qu'est
ce qu'on a c'est de la craie donc ça
quand même facilité le travail c'est une
roche très friable
il serait aussi été fait par d'éminents
professionnels des mineurs du pays de
galles donc faisait partie de l'armée
britannique et qui sont venus prêter
main forte dans l'armée des souterrains
qui était énormément précieux qui